à londres le sujet était incontournable
pour le premier ministre britannique
il avait soigneusement préparé sa
réponse pour la presse en pleine journée
du commonwealth
boris johnson sent le besoin de réitérer
son admiration pour la reine alors que
la monarchie britannique traverse une
autre tempête la veille
megan marco avait accusé le palais de
buckingham de racisme et de l'avoir
poussé au bord du suicide
les allégations explosives ont fait
réagir aux quatre coins du commonwealth
jusqu'en nouvelle zélande
ce pays est une monarchie
constitutionnelle comme le canada la
reine et son chef d'état le moment
est-il venu de couper les liens avec la
couronne demande les journalistes je ne
sens pas d'appétit pour un changement
constitutionnel dit la première ministre
à ottawa c'est silence radio
le gouvernement trudeau a refusé de
commenter les plus récents déchirement
de la famille royale
des membres de l'opposition remettent en
doute la raison d'être de la monarchie
je considère que les sur la monarchie
est complètement dépassée archaïque
moyenâgeuse et non démocratique
et si je peux me permettre de soutien
diana jones leur place est dans un musée
selon un sondage de la firme angus reid
plus de la moitié des canadiens jugent
que la famille royale n'est plus
pertinente au québec
le désaveu est encore plus fort la
monarchie est une institution dépassée
mais le simple des banques on voit l'eau
ne m'apparait et locke le départ de la
gouverneure générale julie payette et la
controverse autour d'un climat de
travail toxiques haridwar n'aide en rien
redonner du lustre à l'institution
justin trudeau doit bientôt choisir son
successeur et promet un nouveau
processus de sélection j'espère vu que
on aura un nouveau gouverneur général
bientôt qui pourra redonner dignité et
le prestige à pied mais le mandat du
gouverneur général doit aussi changer
selon certains et qui leur sont confinés
que harcèlement et est le racisme et
tolérance zéro et que ce soit aussi
dans leur mandat malgré la désaffection
grandissante des canadiens pour la
monarchie
couper entièrement les liens n'est pas
chose facile il faudrait l'accord de
toutes les provinces et des deux
chambres du parlement
déjà en temps normal un débat
constitutionnel n'était pas une priorité
pour le gouvernement
encore moins en pleine pandémie ici
louis blouin radio canada